und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend es gibt sie die
wirtschaftlichen Gewinner des Krieges
und zu ihnen zählen einige Unternehmen
aus der Rüstungsindustrie kaum einer
profitiert allerdings so enorm wie
reinmetall deren Kurs ist seit
Kriegsbeginn um über
150 Prozent gestiegen und auch ihr
Ansehen das ist vielleicht nicht
unbedingt gestiegen aber es hat sich
verändert denn viele Menschen in
Deutschland finden eine Unterstützung
der Ukraine mit Waffen weiterhin richtig
und die liefert ja nun mal die
Rüstungsindustrie und sie soll mehr
liefern 20 dieser Unternehmen waren
heute auch deshalb zum Treffen der NATO
Verteidigungsminister eingeladen vom
Generalsekretär persönlich das gab es so
tatsächlich noch nie ultra
Armin pappberger ist Chef des
Rüstungskonzerns rein Metall und zu Gast
bei der NATO er hat heute viele
Verteidigungsminister getroffen
Milliarden Aufträge winken das
Hauptquartier des mächtigsten
Militärbündnisses geschäftlich ein
Traumort für ihn normalerweise sitzt man
um einen großen runden Tisch es waren
viele kleine Tische und wir hatten viele
viele Diskussionen so im Grunde genommen
wie ein bisschen wie ein Speed Dating
Speeddating in Kriegszeiten die Zukunft
für Waffenproduzenten ist rosig hohe
zweistellige Wachstumsraten worüber wir
uns immer unterhalten und ich glaube das
funktioniert jetzt auch wir dürfen nicht
reden über ein oder zwei Jahre wir
müssen über einen Zeitraum von 7 8 9 10
Jahren reden um dann auch vernünftig
produzieren zu können er will groß
bestellen lassen
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg hat
eine einfache Botschaft mitgebracht der
Krieg dauert lange deshalb müssen mehr
Waffen produziert werden
Micky schildert sicherstellen dass die
gelieferten Waffen auch weiter
funktioniert wir müssen dauerhaft genug
Munition und Ersatzteile produzieren
damit wir kämpfen können
das große Thema auf dem Treffen die
gegen Offensive der Ukraine in der NATO
sieht man Erfolge und Gelände Gewinne
und verspricht mehr Waffen zu liefern
der Kampf ist ein Marathon kein springt
wir werden der Ukraine alles zur
Verfügung stellen damit sie jetzt
erfolgreich ist aber auch in Zukunft
keine Angst mehr haben muss vor einer
russischen Aggression
der Krieg ist auch ein Krieg der Bilder
die Russen behaupten westliche Panzer zu
zerstören drohnenaufnahmen als Beweis
für die großen militärischen Erfolge
ihre Armee
auch die Ukrainer vermelden Erfolge die
Fahne weht über befreiten Gebiet der
Westen beobachtet die Gegenoffensive
genau hofft auf Geländegewinne experten
rechnen mit einem zermürbenden
Stellungskrieg
es gibt keine schnellen sie keinen
schnellen Erfolg sondern eher ein
langsames durchkämpfen mit durchaus
signifikanten Verlust noch ukrainischer
Seite alle Augen sind auf ihn gerichtet
den ukrainischen Verteidigungsminister
über Verluste wollte er nicht sprechen
sondern lieber alle daran erinnern für
wen die Ukraine kämpft
unsere Truppen werden zum Schutzschild
der Ostflanke Europas und der NATO
werden
zur NATO-Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine
wurden abgewürgt das Bündnis will diese
Debatte nicht
deswegen steht im Augenblick wenn ich
das noch mal sagen da vor allen Dingen
die anhaltende substanzielle
Unterstützung der Ukraine im Vordergrund
und nicht die Spekulation darüber was
nach dem Krieg sein wird was nach dem
Krieg sein wird darauf haben Sie hier
keine Antwort heute ging es um massive
Aufrüstung der Frieden lässt auf sich
warten
so wie auch ein konkreter Zeitplan für
eine NATO-Beitritt der Ukraine klar ist
einem Beitritt wird es während des
Krieges nicht geben dann sonst würde die
NATO ja Kriegspartei werden die Lösung
könnte ein Zwischenschritt sein eine Art
Partnerschaft auf Augenhöhe aber wie
kommt diese Idee an in Brüssel und in
Kiew beginnen wir bei Florian neuhahn in
Brüssel schönen guten Abend Florian die
Rede ist jetzt aktuell von einem NATO
Ukraine Rat und oder
Sicherheitsgarantien was hat es damit
auf sich
na bisher gibt es eine
nato-ukrainekommission die soll jetzt
aufgewertet werden zu einem nato-ukraine
Rat bei der NATO gibt man sich
allergrößte Mühe diesen diese Aufwertung
als großen Fortschritt zu bezeichnen zu
beschreiben weil die Ukraine damit
erstmals gleichberechtigt mit am Tisch
säße aber ehrlicherweise ist das doch
eher ein Fortschritt für Feinschmecker
anders könnte es mit diesen
Sicherheitsgarantien oder
sicherheitszusagen aussehen die
einzelnen NATO-Staaten abgeben können
die Ukraine eben weiter vor allem auch
militärisch zu unterstützen doch wie
hart und wie konkret diese Zusagen sein
werden das ist derzeit noch völlig offen
dann gehen wir rüber zu Alisa jung in
saporicia in Kiew dürfte diese Absage
nach einem konkreten Zeitplan zum
Beitritt in die Natur nicht besonders
auf große Freude oder auf Erleichterung
treffen macht man sich denn Freunde mit
diesem Zwischenschritt
Präsident selensky kann damit gar nicht
voll zufrieden sein denn am Ende ist das
was die Ukraine will und braucht der
Beitritt zur NATO Artikel 5 die
Beistandspflicht der Kern des
nato-vertrags die Ukraine wartet seit
Jahren auf den NATO-Beitritt in nach
ukrainischer Lesart wäre das Land gar
nicht von Russland überfallen worden
wäre man Mitglied der NATO gewesen und
so macht Präsident selensky klar am Ende
steht für ihn der schnelle NATO-Beitritt
und nichts weniger und fordert auch ein
Zeichen von der NATO ein Zeichen er sagt
Angst und falsche Rücksichtnahme das
befeuere nur die Aggressionen Russlands
er hat sich am Mittwoch verständigt mit
Präsident du da dem polnischen
Präsidenten auf eine gemeinsame Linie
für den NATO-Gipfel im Juli denn für die
Ukraine für präsidentinski so sagt er
sei die NATO Mitgliedschaft immer noch
die beste Sicherheitsgarantie also der
sind die Erwartungen weiter hoch Florian
wenn wir bei Erwartungen sind sind die
nach weiteren Militärhilfen denn heute
erfüllt worden
es gab durchaus weitere Ankündigungen
und Zusagen vor allem von vier Staaten
den USA Großbritannien Niederlanden und
Dänemark die wollen hunderte weitere
militärflugabwehrraketen liefern für
kleinere und mittlere Reichweite also
genau das was die Ukraine jetzt braucht
um russische Angriffe aus der Luft
abzuwehren aber es gab auch andere
Nachrichten etwa wenn es um diese Panzer
geht diese Leopard 2 A6 Panzer die ja
offenbar zerstört worden sind da hat der
deutsche Minister klar gemacht dass es
keinen schnellen Ersatz dafür geben wird
weil die Deutschen eben ihre anderen
ihre eigenen Panzer noch brauchen selbst
für die eigene Verteidigung also die
Waffenlieferungen gehen weiter aber man
stößt mittlerweile auch an echte Grenzen
dann vielen Dank an euch beide für eure
Einschätzungen und alles Gute
und damit kommen wir nach Deutschland
das sogenannte heizungsgesetz sorgt
nicht nur bei manch einem Bürger bzw
Bürgerin für Schnappatmung sondern heute
auch bei diversen Politikern im
Bundestag anders kann man sich Worte wie
spezialdemokraten zum Kotzen verkorkst
für die Tonne und einiges mehr kaum
erklären der Sache und der Debatte um
die Sache dient das alles nicht genauso
wenig wie die Aussage von Robert Habeck
das in der knapp zweiseitigen Einigungen
der Koalition von Dienstag Zitat noch
sehr viele ungenaue Formulierungen drin
stehen weil man sich noch nicht komplett
einig sei
über diese zwei Seiten die lediglich
angefügt wurden an den alten Entwurf des
Wirtschaftsministers und über die
Debatte an sich bin ich ja
er bringt seine Rede in letzter Minute
zu Papier Robert Habeck hat keine
aktualisierte Fassung des Gesetzes dabei
keine definitiven Zahlen oder Daten was
die Opposition genüsslich aufspießen
wird der Minister bleibt nur der Versuch
repräsentativ und nicht zu zerrupft zu
wirken politisch danke das ist jetzt
aufgesetzt wurde ich denke es ist
tatsächlich zumindestens departier reif
aus meiner Sicht dann auch
entscheidungsreif es ist ja nicht so das
ist ja nicht so dass es geheim gewesen
wäre was in diesem Gesetz steht sondern
Deutschland hat sich ja intensiv damit
befasst und die Fraktion natürlich auch
intensiv heißt immer noch nicht
endgültig es sind immer noch zu viele
entscheidende Fragen offen gibt selbst
einer aus der Koalition zu das darf man
überhaupt nicht verschweigen dass
zwischen FDP zwischen grün und SPD ein
unterschiedlicher Ansatz besteht wenn es
um Finanzierung des Staates und dieser
Maßnahmen geht aber ich bin sicher auch
nach den letzten Tagen wir werden das
Stemmen den Swiss weiß die Opposition zu
nutzen
waren kritisiert das falsche Spiel der
FDP und skizziert Habeck Hausaufgaben
wenn ich nächstes Jahr als Bürger eine
Gasheizung einbaue muss ich die dann
2008 da ist sie sagen ja sie sagen nein
wird es vor Einbau einer Gasheizung eine
verpflichtende Beratung geben sagen die
Grünen oder ein Beratungsangebot sagt
die FDP ein ziemlicher Unterschied damit
wäre zu dieser ersten Lesung schon alles
gesagt wenn das Publikum nicht eine Rüge
von ganz oben hören würde nach diesem
rhetorischen Stammtisch von Union AFD
und Linken wie sie kommunizieren und wie
sie Angst auslösen ist unterirdisch ist
zum kotzen und dann rotzen Sie uns hier
etwas hin Heizungs-
und bevor die Wörter rotzen und kotzen
hier inflationär weitergebraucht werden
bitte ich wirklich alle noch mal im
Namen auf der Würde des Hauses
auch bei hitzigen Debatten vielleicht
das zu unterlassen kurz später folgt die
Rede des afd-abgeordneten Hilse er nennt
die Ampel spezialdemokraten grüne
Kommunisten feige Demokraten manche Volk
bezeichnen ihre Politik inzwischen als
einen Krieg gegen das eigene Volk und
jeder der sich an diesem Krieg beteiligt
wird sich der einst vor diesem Volk
verantworten müssen die einzige Partei
die sich gegen diesen kollektiven Suizid
stemmt ist die AFD eine solide nazi-rede
ruft der Mann ganz links im Bild
anschließend ins Plenum dafür kassiert
der linke Abgeordnete Korte nachträglich
eine Verwarnung
hat schon mehrfach darauf hingewiesen
dass wir es für unangemessen halten mit
dem Begriff im Nazi so Inflation
umzugehen wie es gegenseitig geschieht
die Rede des AFD Mannes wird von der
Bundestagspräsidentin nicht geahndet die
erste Lesung ist damit geschafft mehr
aber noch nicht Klarheit herrscht immer
noch nicht über den Inhalt des Gesetzes
wohl aber über den Zustand deutscher
Politik sowas kommt von sowas
und wir blicken jetzt noch einmal auf
die ukrainische Situation in den
Nachrichten mit Gundula bzw auf dem
Präsidenten der Ukraine der ukrainische
Präsident selenski hat einen globalen
Friedensgipfel in der Schweiz
vorgeschlagen außerdem bat er das
neutrale Land um Waffen um den Frieden
wiederherstellen zu können so sagte er
es in einer Videobotschaft an das
Schweizer Parlament es gehe um den
Schutz der Welt vor dem Krieg die
Schweiz lehnt Waffenlieferungen ab und
hält an ihrer Neutralität fest diese
sieht die rechtspopulistische
schweizerische Volkspartei durch den
Auftritt selenskys gefährdet und blieb
der Sitzung fern
russland will am 10 September in den
annektierten ukrainischen Gebieten
Wahlen abhalten in Teilen der Regionen
donetz luansk Hassan und saporicia
unterdessen stufte der Chef der
Internationalen Atomenergiebehörde
grossi bei einem Besuch des russisch
besetzten Kernkraftwerk saporisia die
Lage dort als ernst ein es würden aber
Maßnahmen zur Stabilisierung ergriffen
aufgrund der Zerstörung des kachowka
Staudamms ist die Kühlung der
stillgelegten Reaktoren mit Wasser
gefährdet
aus ganz Deutschland sind Exil Iraner
nach Berlin gereist um einen Protesttag
gegen das iranische mularegime zu
unterstützen an den Aktionen unter dem
Titel Frau Leben Freiheit beteiligten
sich Wissenschaftler Kunstschaffende und
Politiker ihr Ziel Solidarität mit der
iranischen Revolution und ihren Opfern
dazu im heute journal Update ein
Gespräch mit der Deutsch iranischen
Autorin Gilde sahibi
nach dem schweren Bootsunglück gestern
vor Griechenland gibt es kaum Hoffnung
auf weitere Überlebende die Behörden
rechnen mit hunderten weiteren
Todesopfern laut Augenzeugen könnten bis
zu 750 Menschen an Bord des in Ägypten
gestarteten Fischkutters gewesen sein 78
Tote wurden bislang geborgen nur
104 Menschen konnten gerettet werden
die Ministerpräsidenten der Länder haben
bei ihren Beratungen mit Bundeskanzler
Scholz die längst vereinbarte
Beschleunigung von Genehmigungsverfahren
eingefordert zügig werde nun eine
Arbeitsgruppe eingesetzt erklärte Scholz
weitere Themen der Aufbau eines
wasserstoffnetzes und die
Flüchtlingspolitik hier konkret die
Kostenverteilung der
eu-asylkompromiss habe so
Ministerpräsident weil nahezu einhellige
Zustimmung gefunden
und wir bleiben beim Thema Flucht und
Vertreibung und da liegt es
wahrscheinlich in der Natur des Menschen
dass er bei manchen sein einfach
abstumpft bei dem einen oder der anderen
mag es ein Mangel an Interesse oder
Empathie sein doch bei vielen ist es
wohl eher eine Art Strategie um mit dem
Wahnsinn auf der Welt fertig zu werden
Millionen hungernder Kinder zigtausend
Ertrinkende Menschen im Mittelmeer oder
Menschen auf der Flucht ganz generell
die Zahl die das Hilfswerk UNHCR gestern
dazu veröffentlicht hat ist so hoch wie
nie zuvor 110 Millionen Menschen die
meisten von ihnen sind Binnenvertriebene
und an der Spitze steht seit Jahren
Syrien und jetzt soll es dort erstmals
seit Beginn des Bürgerkriegs vor zwölf
Jahren in sämtlichen Verwaltungsbezirken
eine humanitäre Notlage geben nicht nur
deshalb kommt der siebte Geber Gipfel
bzw die siebte Geberkonferenz in Brüssel
gerade recht goldene atai über das Leben
und Leid der Menschen
gestrandet im Nirgendwo bei Rakka im
Nordosten Syriens bauen sie aus der Not
Bambushütten für die neuen Flüchtlinge
50 Familien vertrieben aus dem Libanon
wie den Kindern hier erklären wo die
Väter sind fragen sich die Mütter manche
Männer seien sofort nach dem
Grenzübertritt zum Militärdienst
eingezogen worden andere flohen damit
sie nicht das gleiche Schicksal er alt
libanesische Armee machte eine Razzia um
4 Uhr früh alle auch die Kinder sie
rissen uns aus dem Bett und brachten uns
zur syrischen Grenze
leben in einer permanenten Notlage auch
hier im Nordwesten Syriens im
oppositionsgebiet
ingeniederes wo der Schutt des Erdbebens
immer noch nicht ganz aufgeräumt wurde
ist keine Hilfe angekommen stehen immer
noch Zelte zwischen den zerstörten
Häusern
arbeitete als Friseur aber sein Salon
steht nicht mehr im Zelt ist es
unerträglich heiß sagt er es gibt kein
Trinkwasser er lebt von zwei
Essenspaketen im Monat wo bleibt die
Hilfe der Welt beim Wiederaufbau fragt
er sich
nachdem wir die Hilfskonvois sahen
dachten wir dass unser Leben irgendwie
weitergehen wird dass sie wenigstens
Zweizimmerwohnungen oder irgendetwas
kleines für uns bauen wir hätten nicht
gedacht dass es nur ein Essenspaket gibt
und sonst nichts
Leben als Flüchtling bedeutet auch dass
endlose Warten auf Gerechtigkeit
adnanal sehen demonstrierte gegen
Machthaber Assad und wurde in assets
Gefängnissen wie ein Kriegs Gefangener
behandelt sagt er von zehn Angehörigen
fehlt jede Spur Jahre später erkannte er
seinen Bruder wieder auf
hinausgeschmuggelten gefängnisfotos tot
und gefoltert
ich wünsche mir dass die Vereinten
Nationen oder die Großmächte uns
unterstützen unsere Fälle vor
internationale Gerichte zu bringen um
dieses Regime für seine Verbrechen
haften zu lassen
in Brüssel formulierte die syrische
Zivilgesellschaft heute den gleichen
Wunsch an die Welt ein folter-regime
können nicht einfach normalisiert werden
und ein anderer Wunsch ist heute in
Erfüllung gegangen auf der
syrien-geber-konferenz in Brüssel
in Kairo nämlich der nach Geld bisher
sind 5,6 Milliarden Euro
zusammengekommen aber kommt es auch da
an wo es hin soll
also auch wenn das mehr ist als ich
heute morgen noch vor Beginn der
Konferenz mutmaster bleibt es insgesamt
zu wenig das bestätigt da heute auch der
regionalschiff des Internationalen Roten
Kreuzes es ist ungefähr die Hälfte des
angepeilten Betragens und dieses zu
wenig das ist nicht erst seit diesem
Jahr so das ist geht schon seit 2016 und
manche unzusagen die bleiben dann
einfach im Laufe des Jahres aus der
Syrien Konflikte geht jetzt ins 13 Jahr
es ist ein Gewöhnungseffekt insgesamt
eingetreten das haben sich andere Krisen
in den Vordergrund geschoben wie die
Ukraine wie Syrien nur der Bedarf vor
Ort der ist wirklich größer den jeder
denn es gibt kaum noch
Bildungsmöglichkeiten es gibt kaum noch
psychosoziale Unterstützung für die
Menschen und die medizinische Versorgung
gerade in Nordsyrien die ist schlechter
denn je es sind 15 Millionen Syrer
insgesamt auf humanitäre Hilfe
angewiesen und über 90% der Syrer leben
unterhalb der Armut Schwelle und dieser
Mangel an humanitärer Hilfe der ist umso
frustrierender als das keine politische
Lösung in Sicht ist und die Hilfe für
Nordwest Syrien die hängt immer noch am
Seiten den Faden die muss alle sechs
Monate erneuert werden im
UN-Sicherheitsrat und hängt von Russland
Stimme dort ab und das Geld ist ja nicht
nur für Syrien sondern auch für die
aufnehmenden Nachbarländer wie z.B dem
Libanon gedacht goldene atai vielen Dank
nach Kairo
und wir machen jetzt weiter mit der
Wirtschaft und diagondola
die Europäische Zentralbank hat wie
erwartet den Leitzins noch einmal
angehoben um 0,25 Punkte auf glatt vier
Prozent damit hat sie ihren Kurs im
Kampf gegen die hohe Inflation
fortgesetzt ist aber noch lange nicht am
Ziel von eigentlich zwei Prozent
Inflation Frank Widmann wie wird der
heutige Zinsschritt an der Börse
bewertet er den hat man mehrheitlich
genauso erwartet Tenor die EZB mache
jetzt nach zuvor viel Kritik einen guten
Job der Kampf gegen die Inflation habe
weiterhin oberste Priorität schließlich
liegt die Teuerung in der Eurozone noch
immer bei über 6 % und ezb-chefin
Christine lagard verwies heute auf die
neueste Prognose demnach würde die
Inflation hier noch länger hoch bleiben
man arbeite weiter am Ziel sie wieder
auf zwei Prozent zu drücken deswegen
also hierzulande anders als in den USA
wo die Inflation inzwischen auf vier
Prozent gesunken ist keine Zinspause
und was bedeutet die Zinserhöhung
hierzulande für Sparer werden sie
endlich auch davon profitieren Sie
profitieren nur mit Zeitverzögerung
davon wenn überhaupt das ist das
erstaunlichste seit über einem Jahr hat
die EZB ihre Nullzinspolitik beendet
doch noch immer zahlt jedes vierte
Geldhaus von rund 800 Banken seinen
Kunden keine Zinsen aufs Tagesgeld laut
Vergleichsportal Verivox bringen 10.000
Euro auf einem Tagesgeldkonto im Schnitt
1,1 Prozent legt man das Geld für zwei
Jahre fest an gibt es im Schnitt 2,7%
Zinsen in der Spitze gibt es bessere
Angebote und das nicht nur für Neukunden
die besseren Zinsen kommen aber nicht
automatisch zu einem man muss sie suchen
vielen Dank
nahe Schloss Neuschwanstein in Bayern
sind zwei junge Touristen in den Opfer
einer Gewalttat geworden offenbar waren
sie von einem Mann einen Abhang hinab
gestoßen worden hier Bilder eines
Augenzeugen eine der beiden attackierten
Freundinnen er lag ihren Verletzungen
sie sollen ebenso wie der mutmaßliche
Täter den sie zufällig begegneten
Touristen aus den USA sein Hintergrund
könnte laut Ermittlern ein versuchtes
Sexualdelikt gewesen sein
Polens Umweltministerium hat einen
Krisenstab einberufen nach dem Fund
mehrere hundert Kilo toter Fische in
Seitenkanälen der oder es soll nun
schnell gehandelt werden um die
Entwicklung der nachgewiesenen giftigen
goldalge zu stoppen im vergangenen
Sommer war es in der oder zu einem
massenhaften Fischsterben gekommen ein
Grund soll die goldige gewesen sein
die britische Schauspielerin und Oskar
Preisträgerin Blender Jackson ist im
Alter von 87 Jahren in London gestorben
nach 35 erfolgreichen Jahren auf
Theaterbühnen und den Hollywood
wechselte sie in die Politik war
Parlamentsabgeordnete für die
laber-partei und
Staatssekretärin im Kabinett leer zwei
Oscars erhielt sie so 1971 als beste
Hauptdarstellerin in woman in Love das
Wetter ist so wundervoll vielleicht
können wir warten
wir drehen die Uhr 70 Jahre zurück
dieses Foto es steht wie kaum ein
anderes für das was am 17 Juni 1953 in
der DDR geschah ein Foto das im Grunde
sehr eindrücklich den ungleichen Kampf
zeigt zwischen einer Millionen
ostdeutscher Bürger und der Diktatur der
SED die war damals vom Volksaufstand
komplett überrumpelt der
Sicherheitsapparat hatte komplett
versagt und der Frust der Arbeiter der
wurde komplett unterschätzt am Ende
wurde der Wunsch nach Freiheit und
Selbstbestimmung dann aber doch mit
Panzern niedergeschlagen wie wichtig
dieser Tag bis heute für die Menschen in
Ostdeutschland ist ist übrigens nicht
gering zu schätzen und daher ist es auch
wichtig auch wenn dieser Tag kein
offizieller Feiertag mehr ist an das was
damals passiert ist zu erinnern auch für
die die damals mutig wie verzweifelt auf
begehrt haben Chris hat Läpple über den
Volksaufstand der mehr war als nur ein
Arbeiteraufstand
die Hauptstadt erinnert an den 17 Juni
auf dem Prachtboulevard Unter den Linden
vor der russischen Botschaft ist dieses
ikonische Bild von Brandenburger Tor zu
sehen halb verdeckt hinter der Fahne
eine junge Studentin von der
Humboldt-Uni es ist kurz nach 12 Uhr als
am 17 Juni 53 die rote Fahne von
Brandenburger Tor geholt wird für wenige
Minuten weht Schwarz-Rot-Gold mit dabei
eine Frau im weißen Kleid die Studentin
Ingeborg im RIAS tunarchiv entdecken wir
ein Original Interview 70 Jahre danach
klopfenden Herzen kamen wir rüber
hinter uns waren die russischen Panzer
wir kletterten dann die die Leiter und
und eben diese ganzen Vorrichtungen
darauf und schwanger dann oben ganz frei
unsere Fahnen unten jubelte die Menge
wir wussten jetzt hatten wir irgendetwas
erreicht die Stimmung ist aufgeputscht
die rote Fahne wird verbrannt es sind
dramatische Stunden mitten im Kalten
Krieg
plötzlich Rollen sowjetische Panzer der
Ausnahmezustand wird verhängt was war
das vor 70 Jahren ein Volksaufstand oder
ein faschistischer Putschversuch
es war der erste Volksaufstand die erste
Revolution die im besetzten Osteuropa
stattgefunden hat das ist der 91-Jährige
Lutz rakko damals Journalist sein Bruder
informierte ihn am 16 Juni über wilde
Streiks an der Stalin Erleben der
Ostberliner setzt sich spontan auf sein
Motorrad da will ich sofort los und
natürlich heimlich der sich war
keineswegs beauftragt dazu der
21-Jährige folgt dem Protestmarsch der
Bauarbeiter zum Haus der Ministerien
dort fordern tausende freie Wahlen und
die sofortige Rücknahme der 10%igen Norm
Erhöhung doch die SED ist abgetaucht
aber das Verhalten war Ziel es gab keine
Übergriffe irgendjemanden es war ja auch
niemand da gewesen
der Funke springt am 17 Juni auf die
ganze DDR über 700 Orte melden Proteste
in Jena erlebt der damals 11-jährige
Günther Töpfer wie eine wütende Menge
nacheinander Gefängnis
fdj-kreisleitung
Gewerkschaftshaus und sed-zentrale
stormt die Frau nahm die Gewehre auf die
aus diesem Gebäude rausgeschmissen
werden steckte sie mit dem Lauf in
diesen Gulli Rost hinein eine kurze
Schwenkbewegung und
die die Waffe war entsorgt und für
nichts mehr zu gebrauchen auch in Jena
Rollen am Nachmittag sowjetische Panzer
Warnschüsse fallen die Menge flieht in
der DDR werden mehr als 10.000 Menschen
verhaftet mindestens 55 Sterben der
Volksaufstand scheitert dennoch war der
17 Juni ein Meilenstein auf dem Weg zur
friedlichen Revolution von 89
heute vor 70 Jahren und damit wieder
zurück ins Jetzt und zu Maybrit Illner
die Runde diskutiert über den Krieg der
Russen schwierige Offensive putinsstärke
unterschätzt
und um kurz nach halb eins meldet sich
Nazan gökte mir mit unserem heute
journal Update das war es von uns beiden
für heute wir sehen uns morgen wieder
machen sie es gut wo auch immer sie sind
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend richtig heiß ist es zur Zeit
schon im Süden Spaniens und Portugals da
liegen die Temperaturen bei 30 zum Teil
sogar nah an die 40 Grad und diese Hitze
macht sich jetzt bis zum Anfang der
kommenden Woche auf in Richtung
Mitteleuropa dann liegen die Werte auch
bei uns auch mal häufiger über 30 Grad
das wird allerdings mit sehr viel
Feuchtigkeit einhergehen denn den
strahlenden Sonnenschein werden wir zum
Anfang der kommenden Woche los dann gibt
es deutlich mehr Gewitter von Südwesten
heute Nacht gibt's auch einige
Regenschauer hier in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern z.B Richtung
Niedersachsen und auch am alten Rand im
Westen ist es dagegen klar der winterzug
kommt aus westlichen Richtungen und die
Temperaturen sinken auf 14 Grad an der
Nordsee unterm Niederrhein und bis acht
Grad im Vogtland und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen und auch in der Uckermark
um die 19 Grad am Rhein wird es wärmer
mit bis zu 25 Grad und morgen gibt es
deutlich mehr Wolken als heute und es
kann auch kräftiger regnen bis zu fünf
Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter sind
möglich in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern im
nördlichen Brandenburg oder auch in
Niedersachsen am Nachmittag entwickeln
sich dann vor allen Dingen über den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen und am
Alpenrand einige Regenschauer und
Gewitter im Westen bleibt es dagegen
trocken und auch am Samstag und am
Sonntag beschränken sich Regenschauer
und Gewitter im Wesentlichen auf den
Nordosten dann dreht die Wetterlage am
Montag wird es dann von Südwesten schwül
warm und gewittrig guten Abend